BROMLEIGH MCCLENEGHAN:
Good afternoon.
I'm very excited to
be with you today.
When I learned that
Google did author talks
was a number of years ago, when
we had actually first written
our parenting book.
But it was from a
fairly small press,
and it was definitely written
for a limited churchy audience.
And they didn't
think that it would
be particularly interesting.
But when I came to Lauren and
said, I have this book called,
"Good Christian Sex,"
certainly people
would be interested in that.
So I'm delighted to be here.
It's a funny topic to
be writing and talking
about as someone who
is working in churches.
This is not a particularly
academic text.
One of the great things
about pastoral ministry
is that I get to
be a generalist.
So I get to write,
and I get to read,
and I get to hear
people's stories.
And I get to be a part of
the life of a community.
And all of my education always
has been interdisciplinary,
and so allows me to know about
a lot of different things.
So we're going to
talk a little bit
today about some of the
biblical stories that
have shaped the way that
American Christians talk
about sexuality.
But I am not someone who can
get into an argument with you
about the proper pronunciation
or meaning about the Greek
or Hebrew.
You are not going to
ever see my Greek grades
from that year in seminary.
Another thing that I don't
address in the book at any rate
is some of the
biblical texts that
are known in the church
as clobber passages.
Those are the seven
that people like
to trot out to bash queer
folks over the head with.
And I don't really
address those.
They've been looked at by
scholars on all kinds of sides
of the issue.
And so I don't really
talk about those.
I don't want to parse what
has already been discussed.
But I did think that there
was a place for this book.
So just to draw
nice, broad strokes.
In the Christian
tradition-- the part
of the Christian tradition
that I grew up in-- I'm
a preacher's kid,
actually, who has now
written a book about sex.
My parents are
super proud of me.
And the church that I grew up
in was progressive in some ways,
but also largely silent about
issues around sexuality--
about the experiences
of sexuality.
We had some, like,
Christian sex ed
that we were made to go to
as junior high students.
Ours was led at least in part
by my father, which was not even
remotely awkward, and
didn't shape me at all.
But we learned a lot
about the creation story
and God's good
gift of sexuality,
and then basically sort
of, use birth control.
And that was sort of the
end of that discussion.
And so for me personally, a
lot of the-- at least growing
up-- a lot of the narratives
that I had about what healthy
sexuality looked like came from
sophomore health class taught
by the JV basketball coach
and 90210 or "Dawson's Creek"
or, you know, you're 16.
You should probably be sleeping
with whatever boyfriend
you have.
The other sort of strand of
American Christianity that
really started talking a
lot about sex in the '90s,
when I was a teenager,
continued an emphasis
that had begun in the
'80s when it first--
when abstinence-only education
became a part of something that
could get funding in schools.
It actually started during
the Reagan administration,
but sort of ramped up as
part of the Clinton welfare
reform in '96.
And then again, certainly,
when President Bush
introduced the Office of
Faith-based Initiatives.
And so they talked
a lot about that.
And that part of
Christianity really
emphasized abstinence only--
abstinence-only education
and that teenagers,
young adults, everybody
should be fully chaste--
that was the word, chastity--
until they were married.
And anything outside of marriage
was problematic and wrong.
And that narrative
came to really dominate
what people understood was the
Christian understanding of what
holy, good sex was.
And in our world,
and particularly
in the mainline
Protestant congregations
that we grew up in, that was--
I had no idea that was going on.
By the time I read the sort of
seminal text of that movement,
"i Kissed Dating
Goodbye," by Josh Harris.
I was in grad school.
And I read it, and I was like,
well, that ship has sailed.
I'm sort of done with that.
But I was also actually
really angry about it
because it's sort
of a terrible book.
But also because the author,
who was at that point
just a 21-year-old kid
himself wrote this tome
that sort of suggested that--
not just sex, but really
any sort of feeling of
pleasure, or desire,
or of romantic relationship
outside of something that
was leading directly to
marriage-- and in fact
in the moment after
marriage-- was very wrong.
There's one book that he talks
about-- he has the first book,
"I Kissed Dating
Goodbye," and then
he has the sequel is
when he met his wife
and when they started courting--
they did courting, not dating,
which is holier.
At one point, he's sitting
in a hammock-- they're
like head-to-foot, so they're
sitting next to each other
in a hammock.
And they're not even
really touching at all.
But he looks, and he
starts to admire her legs.
And he then is overcome by a
feeling of his own sinfulness.
And he has to picture Jesus
bleeding on the cross in order
to right his mind and get his
mind out of the gutter again.
This is, like, a month
before their wedding.
So that book had
a huge effect on--
AUDIENCE: --you'd think it'd
mess up his wedding at all.
BROMLEIGH MCCLENEGHAN: No.
No.
They are going to just
totally set that baggage aside
right away.
But not only for them, but
for really a generation
of American
Christians growing up
in a certain part of the
church, his book and others
then like it, along with
True Love Waits and some
of these other movements,
really affected the way
that we talk about sexuality.
As someone who
identifies as a Christian
and had some really wonderful
experiences before I
was married, I was
frustrated by the sense
that somehow our sexuality
was something that
could be turned on and off.
There are a whole lot of
disciplines who tell you
that's a terrible idea.
But also the fact
that healthy sexuality
was somehow wholly
distinct from what it
meant to be a faithful person.
So this book has
sort of come out
of this cultural moment
and my personal experience,
but also a real
desire to just talk
about what it feels
like to fall in love,
and, like, meet
somebody that you want
to touch and be touched by.
I'm ordained in the United
Methodist Church, which,
like many other
churches, we were often
very silent on issues of what
healthy sexuality looked like.
But we definitely have a,
like, don't ask, don't tell.
You'll probably figure it out.
If you really are
in a crisis, you
can come and talk
to your pastor,
and maybe they will
give you good advise.
Maybe not.
But the issue that
we really focused on
is LGBTQ inclusion around
ordination, around marriage.
That has been the dominant
conversation and fight.
And it's been ugly and horrible.
And while some denominations
are on the better side of it,
the Methodist Church is
still really mired in it.
And so part of my hope then,
too, in addressing these topics
is to help offer an entry point.
I don't think all
people are the same,
and all people believe
all the same things.
But I do think that it
can be helpful to folks
to give them a way to
identify with other people.
So I kind of wanted to
unpack the experience
of falling in love, or
of seeking pleasure,
or of following your desires.
So the book takes up
questions of sexuality,
but also relationships and love.
And then the final
impetus-- I now
work in a local congregation.
But I used to work at the
University of Chicago.
And so I worked with a lot of
college students and graduate
students.
And certainly with some
of the Title IX stuff,
and just being on
a college campus,
you can't ignore the very
open wounds of rape culture.
That's really all around.
The questions about what's
the nature of consent?
And how do we get it?
And how do we ask for it?
There's lots of hand-wringing
about hook up culture.
And I really wanted to
not do hand-wringing.
I don't know.
I went to college,
and I met some people.
But at the same
time, I was talking
to a friend of mine
just the other day who
is a college chaplain.
And she and her husband, who's
on the faculty at the college
where she works also--
the students came to them,
and they wanted the couple
to do panel discussion
on how you date.
They know how to get wasted
and sleep with somebody
they don't really know.
But they have no idea
how to build intimacy.
Aside from any
moral questions we
might have about what it means
that you have to knock yourself
out in order to
pursue something,
it's very hard to
have enjoyable,
pleasurable experiences
if you can't communicate
at all with your partner.
So there's probably some need to
like teach communication skills
to people.
So that's my interest
in-- for younger readers.
So that's kind of the framework
in which this book came out of.
And so I wanted to
then share with you--
since the introduction
to the book
went up on a Facebook
first reads program,
I've started getting
all kinds of comments.
I know I've really made
it because I finally
started getting trolled.
All these folks
who are convinced
that I am a heretic
and a sinner,
and I am leading people
down the primrose
path all the way into hell.
And they like to
pull out Bible verses
to tell me why I am wrong
for suggesting that sexuality
is a part of who we are.
And that our bodies are
not separate from our minds
or spirits, but that
we're all sort of just
humans with bodies, and
souls, and all these things.
And that focusing on sexual
ethics, which is my interest,
as opposed to sexual
morality, is a problem.
So they proof text
about all the things.
You have to shun fornication.
And don't you know your body
is a temple of the Holy Spirit.
And all these things.
And so I try to engage the Bible
in-- it's certainly not new,
but a different way.
I don't want to proof text.
The great Christian
ethicist-- she just retired,
I believe, from Yale-- I mean,
I believe she just retired.
She was at Yale.
Margaret Farley wrote
this wonderful book
called, "Just Love."
And it's sort of a
Christian sexual ethics.
And I mean, it's firmly
within the tradition
of Christian ethics.
But she challenges
enough-- she's not a nun,
but she's taken orders.
So she's a Catholic holy woman.
I can't think of what the
word I'm looking for is.
But she's a woman religious.
There you go.
And she got in trouble with
the Vatican for this book.
So it's great.
You know it's good when it's
been knocked by the Vatican.
But it's very much in
keeping with the tradition.
But she has this
great line that's
basically like, you
shouldn't proof text
the Bible about anything.
But you really shouldn't proof
text the Bible about sexuality.
Proof texting, of course,
means just pulling things out
of context and then sort of
saying, well, here it is.
Here's the coherent
list of rules
that we've got right here.
Because that's really just
not how the Bible is written.
It was written over an
extended period of time
by multiple authors.
Parts of it are-- and
have always been--
understood as allegorical.
Parts of them are histories
intentionally offered
from different perspectives.
Parts of them are
letters written
to very particular communities
at different moments in time.
So she says, we have
to be really careful
when we think about
how we're going
to look at biblical texts,
particularly around issues
of sexuality since
they're so fraught.
So she's really wonderful.
And if you ever feel like
you have some weeks to spend
on Christian sexual ethics,
"Just Love" is where to get
started.
But if you don't
have that much time,
you can read my book, which
is far easier to understand,
I think.
The Bible certainly
does offer points
where things seem to
be-- well, let's just
say the Bible offers a
whole bunch of everything.
My biblical hermeneutic--
that's the churchy word
for interpreting
the Bible-- is, yeah
there is a lot of
stuff in there.
And part of my job
then as a pastor
is to interpret the
Bible for people,
like people in my community.
And again, I try not to-- I'm
not an academic in so far as,
I don't parse.
I don't read the original
language most of the time.
But I want to think about
what this story meant
for people in the past, and
what it means for us today.
So one example that
I want to start with
is actually from
the book of Joshua.
And this is an example
of how Joshua is-- he's
the one who succeeds Moses.
So Moses has led the people
out of slavery in Egypt,
and they've gone
through the wilderness.
But Moses doesn't get to
go into the promised land
because he's made some
errors of his own.
And so Joshua takes
over and becomes
the new leader of the people.
The Lord says, I brought
you to the promised land,
and you should go into it.
And it will be yours.
Here it is.
I've given it to you.
The problem when Joshua
and the people arrived
is that the land is
already inhabited.
And in the Book of
Joshua, then the Lord
says, well, no, it's yours.
So go ahead and
wipe everybody out.
Especially make sure you
get the women and children.
You know, like, take them out.
So this is a hugely problematic.
The Lord is commanding genocide.
That is not cool.
So this came up
in the lectionary,
which is one of the ways
of ordering our preaching
schedule.
And so I had it,
and I'm like, well,
God, what am I going
to do with this?
Because this is terrible.
But I pull out the commentaries
and the academic work.
And this is not a
historical moment.
This genocide didn't
actually happen.
The people were a small
and struggling population.
And as they told these
stories over time
about how they had come
to live in the land,
they needed to feel as
though they were powerful
and they were safe.
And so this story becomes,
God commanded us to come in,
and we, by the power of
God, wiped everybody out,
and now it's ours.
So I think that's an
example-- obviously,
that one's not about sexuality--
but an example of how
biblical texts really have to
be looked at in their context.
And some of them, I mean,
you read at face value,
and you're like, no, I get that.
That makes sense.
But some of them, the distance
is a little bit farther.
So the one I want to start with
is actually about masturbation
because you've got
to dive right in.
When I first wrote the
draft of this book,
this first chapter on
self-love didn't exist.
But it became increasingly
clear that I needed to have it.
So I wrote it, and I sent
a draft in to my editor.
And she was like,
do you really want
to start the book this way?
Everybody is going to
put it down right away.
But I think it's actually
a really important thing
because it allows
us-- I mean, one,
it's just an important thing.
I surveyed 350 people
using a Google form,
you guys, about their
history and practice,
their first romantic experience,
their first sexual experience,
about what they heard from
the church growing up.
It was really open-ended.
You are the right
people, probably,
to ask for help
analyzing my data.
But I was really looking to just
kind of hear people's stories.
And one of my questions was,
did you masturbate as a child?
And then how did
you understand it?
And there were a few folks who
were like, no, not interested.
And certainly, no.
That would be a sin
against my chastity.
I can just imagine a
10-year-old telling you that.
But then a whole bunch
of people were like, yes.
Absolutely.
I understood it as awesome.
And some others were like, yes.
Constantly.
So that was refreshing.
But because there was such
an overwhelming response
to that particular question,
it seemed like something
that had to be lifted up.
But also self-love invites us to
consider the topic of pleasure
without asking about a partner,
or desire as something--
I mean, it's just
like-- it's sort
of a purer form of pleasure
without complication.
I don't know if I only know
this because of history classes
and my particular
interest in the topic,
but once upon a time,
masturbation was often
referred to as onanism.
Anybody heard that term ever?
OK.
Right.
And so particularly
in the Victorian era,
you could read about
how engaging in onanism
will give you hairy palms,
and turn you blind, and acne,
and all sorts of
terrible things.
So I wanted to share with
you the story of Onan.
It appears in Genesis, so
the first book of the Bible,
later on in it.
So it goes like this.
"It happened at that
time that Judah went down
from his brothers and settled
near a certain Adullamite whose
his name was Hirah.
There, Judah saw the daughter
of a certain Canaanite
whose name was Shua.
He married her
and went into her.
She conceived and bore a
son and he named him Er.
Again, she conceived and bore
a son whom she named Onan.
Yet again she bore a son,
and she named him Shelah.
She was in Chezib
when she bore him.
Judah took a wife for
Er, his firstborn,
and her name was Tamar.
But Er, Judah's firstborn,
was wicked in the sight
of the Lord.
And the Lord put him to death."
As you do.
"Then Judah said to Onan,
go into your brother's wife
and perform the duty of
a brother-in-law to her.
Raise up offspring
for your brother.
But since Onan knew that the
offspring would not be his,
he spilled his
semen on the ground
whenever he went into his
brother's wife"-- Whenever,
so more than once.
"--so that he would not give
offspring to his brother.
What he did was displeasing
in the sight of the Lord,
and he put him to death also."
The end.
Several things to know
about this passage.
Judah has two sons--
an older and a younger.
They're both married.
And the first one, Er,
whose wife is Tamar, dies.
He was wicked, so he's dead now.
But to be a woman in
a biblical culture
without attachment
to a man was a hugely
problematic and dangerous thing.
You didn't count at all.
If you had a son, great.
You were sort of safe, and
you had a place in society
because you had to
raise him so that he
could have property and a life.
So you mattered that way.
Or you could have a husband.
Onan is encouraged not to
marry Tamar, his sister-in-law,
but rather to give her a son.
And he enjoys her.
But does not give her
a son and, in fact,
actively prevents giving
her a son in the only way
that you could in
biblical Israel.
And so he spills his seed.
And this is displeasing
to the Lord.
So this is the story,
then, of male pleasure
without conception that
becomes the doctrine
of the church-- that sex
should be for procreation.
This is the story
that gets used to talk
about why that's so critical.
AUDIENCE: It sound like it's
very anti the rhythm method.
BROMLEIGH MCCLENEGHAN: Right.
Oh, yes.
Well, because you're not
supposed to use that.
No.
I mean, even good
Catholics are not
supposed to use
the rhythm method.
Not really.
Because every occasion
of sexual congress,
you should be open
to children, right?
Which is, man, I
have three children.
And that is a lot of work.
You have children.
They are a lot of work.
So I can't quite imagine that.
So here is a story then
about a sexual relationship
that has gone awry
and has become sinful.
It's not a mutual sexual
relationship, exactly.
I mean, she's probably
glad in theory
to have the opportunity
to have a son
and then have a
life and livelihood.
But it doesn't actually
seem like this is
a story about self-love, right?
He has a partner, so,
like, [INAUDIBLE].
In my read of the story,
then, Onan's real sin
is that he is shirking his
duty to his sister-in-law.
He's having sex with her,
and presumably enjoying it,
without fulfilling
his obligation,
and actually then
doing injury to her.
The practice of marrying your
sister-in-law, as I said,
or giving your dead
brother an heir
was a means of
security and protection
for a woman who would
otherwise be without support.
Onan has sex with
Tamar but denies
her the means to protect
or sustain herself.
So here, is I think the
actual moral of this text,
if you can sort of say that.
Pursuing pleasure at
a cost to another,
especially a vulnerable other,
is displeasing to the Lord.
So shame on Onan.
I think it's important to
think about these things.
The church, as I
say, that I grew
up in-- the only conversation--
the very limited conversation
that we had was, like, sexuality
is a good gift from God, right?
We had all these nice, happy,
healthy growing up books,
and really there was sort
of no discussion about what
might count as sexual sin.
And so I think it's important
to both affirm that sexuality
is not something dirty,
or shameful, or horrible,
but also to say that there
are ways you can do it wrong.
And not in terms
of who you're with
and not talking about
positions or whatever.
But there are ways
you can do it wrong.
And one of them is
by taking advantage
of a vulnerable other.
The rest of the book
goes through a number
of these things.
And I want to really
just open ourselves
up to questions fairly shortly.
But I wanted to just
sort of suggest to you
that over the centuries,
biblical texts have
been interpreted in
a number of ways.
And they really
always have been.
I'm going to read to you in
closing in just a second,
and as we move into
the time for questions,
a piece of the Song of Songs,
or the Song of Solomon, which
over time has been
used to describe
the sort of wonderful, mutual,
loving relationship between God
and Israel-- the people of
Israel-- or between Christ
and the Church-- the
mutual connection
and mystical union
that is there.
But if you've ever actually
read the Song of Songs,
you might take a different
interpretation of it.
There are two voices in it,
and it moves back and forth.
So the woman speaks
in this excerpt first.
"I was sleeping, but
my heart was awake.
A sound.
My love is knocking.
He says, open for me my
sister, my dearest, my dove,
my perfect one.
My head is soaked with dew,
my hair with the night mists."
She says, "I have
taken off my tunic.
Why should I put it on again?
I have bathed my feet.
Why should I get them dirty?
My love put his hand in
through the latch hole,
and my body ached for him.
I rose.
I went to open for my love,
and my hands dripped myrrh.
My fingers, liquid myrrh over
the handles of the lock."
I read that, and I don't exactly
think of Christ and the church.
I don't know.
So there's this erotic
love poem here situated
in the midst of the Bible.
So part of my-- again,
my hope for the book
is to affirm that
desire and pleasure are
important parts of what
it means to be human,
to seek to be in relationship.
To know someone in a
particularly intimate way
can be a remarkably
grace-filled experience.
Grace-- in one of the
thinkers that I particularly
love is-- experiencing grace
is like the feeling of knowing
that you are accepted.
And to be vulnerable
with a partner
and to feel seen,
and known, and loved
is like an the experience
of grace, then, in my mind.
To feel that acceptance.
And can be a powerful,
then, and holy thing.
And so I think this is
such a vital conversation.
I don't think-- to
counter those who
criticize me on
my Facebook page,
that everything always is good.
Not every sexual
thing, because it
is done with our bodies, which
are created by God, we say,
is a good thing.
There are in fact
things that harm others.
And I think that's
one of the things
that looking at some of the
texts can suggest to us.
It's not just about
the letter of the law,
but the spirit of the law.
And part of sexual ethics,
then, in the church--
and I think for all people,
even outside of the church--
is to think about, what are
the norms by which we determine
what is good, and what is
holy, and what is loving?
One more.
In Matthew's Gospel, Jesus is
asked point blank the greatest
of the commandments.
There are hundreds of
laws for the people Israel
and certainly,
countless admonitions
from the apostle Paul
and in the other letters.
But in the Gospels,
from the voice of Jesus,
we hear that his
reply to this question
about what the greatest
of commandments is.
"You must love the Lord your
God with all your heart,
with all your being,
and with all your mind.
This is the first and
greatest commandment.
And the second is like it.
You must love your neighbor
as you love yourself.
All the Law and the prophets
depend on these two commands."
So my hope in this book, in
telling embarrassing stories
about myself and
saying words that
make me blush in public, in
writing something my kid can't
read yet-- she's super mad
about that-- my hope in this
is to start to invite
people to think
about what a faithful
sexual ethics looks like.
What are the things that help
us in all our relationships
to fulfill these commandments?
How do you love God, and
yourself, and your neighbor
as best you can?
Thank you.
Are there any questions?
AUDIENCE: One of
the things I wonder
about is the
relationship between sex
and marriage and the fact that,
in a lot of different cultures,
over the years, they've
been closely tied.
And you could
almost see marriage
as coming from some sort of
a societal stamp of approval
on a sexual relationship.
Or involvement in some way.
And right now,
marriage is almost
like a big ceremony
and a legal proceeding,
and it seems like
it's disassociated
from its original kind of
stamp of approval on the sex,
essentially.
Do you see any role for the
larger community in blessing
a sexual relationship?
BROMLEIGH MCCLENEGHAN:
Like in marriage?
AUDIENCE: Like in marriage.
The use of marriage
for that is like-- it's
been disassociated with that.
And is that appropriate?
And if so, is there
some other way
to have the larger
community involved?
BROMLEIGH MCCLENEGHAN:
So marriage
is a funny thing, right?
Because it has
not been certainly
the same thing in
all times and places.
I mean, yes, it was in some
ways, a stamp of approval,
saying this is the person
you get to have sex with.
And more often than
not, this is the woman
that you kind of like paid
enough to get to have sex with.
Hopefully, she's
interested, too.
I think that like
our sense of marriage
as a romantic
partnering over time
that then receives
this blessing-- I mean,
that is in some ways a
very modern invention.
I like to think
about love and sex
and marriage is a Venn
diagram, where they're each
their own thing, but
there is definitely
a place where they all
kind of come together.
And I think that's a
really wonderful thing when
they can all come together.
And I think there
are certainly--
I know why churches
bless marriages.
There is something
amazing about-- I always
say I never liked the phrase,
taking a leap of faith
until I got married.
I never understood what it was.
I always thought it was
doing something dumb
and hoping for the best.
But in some ways, that's
what getting married is.
You make this huge
promise that you're
going to live together with
somebody and be with them
and love them and be faithful
to them, for the most part.
That's usually what people
promise in their marriages.
And you don't know if it's
going to turn out or not.
I mean, it's written
right there in the vows
that you're going to stay even
in sickness and in health,
and richer and poorer.
So I think that that's a
wonderful and holy thing.
So I don't want the
church to get out
of the marriage business.
But I think there's
also the possibility
for holy and wonderful sexual
relationships not in marriage.
Maybe this is more
than you want to hear.
There's a theologian
who talks about how
any sexual relationship that
you can see the end of-- it's
not holy.
So basically he's saying
you have to be married.
But you can't really know.
I think.
You can't really know if a
marriage is going to end.
You can't really know.
And so to say that
something isn't holy
simply because you
don't know how it's
going to turn out years from
now doesn't seem quite accurate
either.
Does that kind of get
what you were wanting?
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to
hear thoughts on the subject.
BROMLEIGH MCCLENEGHAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So that was good.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: In this room,
perhaps a year or so ago,
an author spoke about her
book about the real Amazons.
And among the
points she made were
that, when you had nomadic
peoples-- before their society
started cutting
up pieces of land
and declaring them
owned by people--
the relationship between the
sexes was more equitable.
But that movement to
an agrarian society
resulted in
effectively ownership
of women being important because
you were contributing your land
and your effort to
feed the offspring,
which might not be yours.
And so that in some
way could be viewed
as the origin of the need to
have societal blessed unions.
And also, the taboo of sex
outside that union because it
undermined that
structure of society.
It seems to me, we're
moving in a direction
where the needs of that
no longer really apply.
For the most part, we don't
have all of the land cut up
and occupied by the
owner of the land who
lives there, creating crops.
Many, many people live
in rented apartments.
You can move in with your mom
if your relationship breaks up.
It seems to me a more
fluid environment.
And so I'm hopeful that we
will over time transition
from structural support
for a society functioning
to more a bond between people.
More holy union rather than--
more matrimony rather than
marriage, you might say.
Less about the finances
and more about the part
that matters-- the love
in the sense of caring,
rather than love in the
sense of euphemism for sex.
BROMLEIGH MCCLENEGHAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
Societies are going
to organize themselves
as they will around any
number of different things.
I counsel a lot of people
that about getting married.
I meet with them
a bunch of times,
and we plan their
service and talk
about what it means
to be married.
And almost every
wedding I've ever done,
the couple has already
lived together.
So they certainly don't seem
to care for my blessing about
whether or not they're
going to be having sex.
Which is cool.
But we do always talk about
the details of married life,
that it's amazing how who's
doing the dishes or not
can affect whether
or not you feel
like going to bed with
them at the end of the day.
I do think that I would
much prefer people
to marry because they desire
to be committed to one another
than because it is
economically feasible.
But I don't think that
we can ever really
divorce the ephemeral
and emotional commitments
from the day-to-day
tasks of life together.
When my husband and I bought
our first house together
the real estate
lawyer's sitting there.
And he's just like, now you
have to both pay for this,
even if this doesn't work out.
We're like, oh, gee thanks.
But honestly, once you have
kids, or you have property,
or whatever-- you
may well have more--
I don't like to speak in
crass economic terms--
but you sort of have more
incentive to work on it
because you can't just
pick up and leave.
Your lives are enmeshed
in certain ways.
But the way that we think about
relationships are different.
And I think part of the
important thing then for us
going forward is not
necessarily being
wed to a particular structure
or a particular institution
as we've understood
it in whatever
historical period,
but to ask, who
does this render vulnerable?
Marriage is good for
raising children.
Children need some stability.
Not all marriages, but
in general, stability
is good for children.
So if we're going to move away
from marriage, how all else
are we going to make sure
that children are cared for
and have what they need?
But at the same time, I think
that an emphasis on marriage--
when marriage equality
passed, we rejoiced.
And that was a wonderful thing.
But there were also voices
within the queer community
that were like, we have a
lot more pressing issues
than marriage.
Thank you very much.
All the victories
have not yet been won.
So I think that, as we
continue in conversation,
we have to keep
track of, how are
vulnerable people being affected
by whatever changes we see?
AUDIENCE: My comment
on moving away
from the financial structure
provided by the way
marriage has been for probably
millennia in some regard,
is that I feel like we need to
divorce the financial contract
from-- that was not an
intentional pun, sorry--
the financial contract from
the union of two people who
care for each other in that
way, in that intimate way.
Because I grew up with what I
consider relatively traditional
family environment, where we
had multiple generations living
together-- a brother and
sister who just inherited
the house that they grew up in
and continued to live in it.
The one who had the better
salary kept working,
and the other one took
care of stuff at home.
But the law would not allow
them to pool their income
and file for taxes together.
There was no possible
way they could
because they were siblings,
even if they were to pretend.
And so we have
financial contracts
that are tied to
traditional relationships,
regardless of whether
the contract really
has any need for
that, and people
who are bound by the
expectation of a married couple
with children, even if
they've never had children.
And so it seems to
me that by having
the birth of a
child or a mortgage,
you have stepped into
this structure that
is necessary to support
that, while you were still
single-- the living together
situation we have now.
Society sees that
you're living together.
Your friends know that
If one of you goes
out with someone else,
your friends are all going to
look at you askance and ask,
what's going on here?
So we have that not fully
married concept socially.
We just don't have it legally.
BROMLEIGH MCCLENEGHAN: Right.
I have another degree
in public policy, too.
And so we do organizational
theory and things like that.
One of the things that
they just emphasize
is, institutions are doing
what they're supposed to do.
They're inherently conservative.
They're supposed to keep
things the same over time.
And so helping
institutions which
are inherently conservative
to adapt to social changes
is ongoing work and doesn't
happen very quickly.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that the current view
is relatively recent.
There's a whole different
spread of ages here.
So my entire life, as far
as I've been able to tell,
the dominant Christian viewpoint
has been abstinence only.
This is bad.
And so on.
So how do you think that
can-- to say be changed sounds
like going in and like forcing
other people to believe
something else, which
isn't good either.
But besides, I
guess, writing a book
that might perhaps appeal--
BROMLEIGH MCCLENEGHAN:
That's what I'm going to do.
What are you going to do?
AUDIENCE: How would you suggest
going about-- as you've seen,
on your Facebook page, you
mentioned lots of people
take offense to
what you're saying.
How do you think we
can help spread it
into the country and
even beyond the country?
BROMLEIGH MCCLENEGHAN: In
the church, for example,
in trying to shift the way that
we talk about sexuality, we,
for the last generation,
in the mainline church,
we've talked about
rights language.
And we've talked about justice.
And I think that's
critically important.
I mean, you don't do ethics
without a concern for justice,
right?
That's not very good ethics.
But I think that you
change hearts and minds
by building bridges, and
inviting conversation,
and asking people to reflect
on their experiences.
In the first church
that I served,
it was a super tiny congregation
with basically little
old ladies.
And our town was
increasingly home
to this-- the town had--
the chamber of commerce
had specifically started
encouraging members
of the queer community to
move to it because they had
great affordable bungalows,
and it was close to the city,
and it was great.
And so for this reason, like,
we have this growing population.
We should have this
conversation about sexuality.
And to see if we could
make a public statement
about whether or not they
would be welcome here
in this congregation.
And so we started having
this conversation, me
and all the old ladies,
and in some ways,
it was just such a
surprising thing.
We started having a
conversation, and this one
woman, Liz, who may or
may not yet be living,
but she said, you know,
when I got married,
I married a Catholic.
And the priest wouldn't
marry us because it was
just outside of the practice.
And she was like,
it's the same thing.
In her mind, her experience
of being turned away
from the church because
of who she was-- it
was totally analogous.
And so I think by asking-- I
mean, it's a little different.
But I think encouraging
people to think
about their experiences
and how they
might be similar to other
people's experiences
I think can be a
way of doing that.
And then for the
church, I think we
have to do the nitty gritty
work of looking at the text
and reflecting on our
theology and making
the case that there's an
alternative-- that there's not
only one Christian way
of talking about this.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
BROMLEIGH MCCLENEGHAN: Thanks.
OK.
Thank you.